all right we're live so you
can take it away whenever
yeah okay um i'll just wait a
couple people are still coming in
so i guess even in the top in the middle of
the pandemic everything is still academic time
i can't actually see the room um is it is there
people are the people there is it still filling up
there's 200 people in the room
one of them being said right now
yeah one of them being me that's true
so i thought we had like a floating
participant who shows the room but i guess not
yeah you see the room is pretty empty were those
animations made in blender sorry who made those
animations uh those particular ones i made you
made them and blender or what this is like pie
food
um sid could you be my eyes and ears
when is the when are we asymptoted on um
people there in the actual room physically i
think this is probably the asymptotic behavior
okay five people including them okay
five people okay um including um
it includes scott and ben okay um all right
michael lachman just joined but i figure
you can probably get started um
okay everybody um ben in uh very uh
exemplary sfi style works on many different
topics so last time we heard him discussing um
aspects of biology down into the nitty-gritty
details of experimental systems um relating it to
issues of thermodynamic efficiency and information
theory um but he's actually done probably i would
say most of your work then um correct me
if i'm wrong um if there is to be the mode
of the work that he's done actually has to do with
things that are somewhat that are that grew out
of jim sethna's work which we've seen before here
within the past year here at the sfi um basically
um how to deal with the huge number of parameters
in statistical models why it is and how it is
that we can actually get science to work in a very
broad sense and so today we are quite fortunate to
have been presenting more um advances
deeper understanding along these lines um
rational ignorance deeper understanding about
rational ignorance there we go so take it away ben
well thank you very much um
that's a wonderful introduction
and it's been a wonderful visit
i've really enjoyed the conversation
lots of people here um and it's it's been a great
a great time um and thanks to all of you who made
it to my talk uh one way or another braving uh the
plague and snowstorms and bad internet connections
um so uh uh i hope this should be casual
and people should ask lots of questions um
um okay so to get people kind of thinking about
the ideas that this talk is going to be about
um here's a just a snapshot of a simulation of
water um water is very complicated it's really
all i want you to take from this if i really
want to understand how a solute that's the
blue and and the blue molecule there
how it how it moves around in water
you'd really need to do a very complicated
simulation um but if all you care about is it's
is its um uh uh translational motion at long time
scales um all you need is this diffusion equation
and somehow all these details um end up mattering
only um through their effects on this one number
something sort of similar happens in
a lot of different models i'm going to
go into more detail about this but here's a
picture of the inside of a cell this is just a
cartoon which is very complicated um and uh you
can write down models that come out of this so
this is the schematic of one of those models
um and in this particular model um all these
things in circles are proteins and the arrows
are are reactions that the proteins carry out
phosphorylations and things like that and
and you can put numbers to all those things
um this particular model has has uh
48 parameters um if you run the model
um you can do a pretty good job of fitting data
um and and i think maybe you'd agree with me that
these are not 48 parameter curves so this has a
height maybe a width this one just has a height
and a maybe there's four or five parameters
there um but there's certainly not 48 um
and indeed um in some work that i'll tell you
just a little bit about um uh mark transtrom
uh was able to show that you could really get
very equivalent behavior with a much simpler
model so this is a schematic for a model that you
reduce this model to which only has 12 parameters
one thing i want you to notice because
it'll be important later is that
even with these 48 parameters um you
can't fit these little bumps right so um
the line does not go through all of this
on the other end
is
is it possible it's my computer's sound microphone
you're very noisy very noisy it's
i think unpleasant coming back
this
um all right that sounds better
uh excellent how's this let's go with this
it's still coming hot
let's go with this
is that better awesome thank you um okay so
so i guess what i want you to take from this
is is partly that this reduced model does do a
good job and then maybe you should be impressed
that even with 48 parameters it is possible
to capture quantitatively some of the things
that's happening in this whole mess okay so so
why do we want why do we prefer a simple model
um uh that and and there's a couple of reasons
that i want to go over quickly one is that
um a simpler model might avoid overfitting so
i showed you that even that complicated model
um didn't do a lot of overfitting um i'll
have a little bit more to say about this
there's also aesthetics um so i think this is a
very valid reason um uh but it's not something
that i'm going to be talking about too much more
here and it might be easier computationally um
but actually i think the reason you might prefer
a simpler model in the case of diffusion and i
will argue also in these systems biology models
um is that most parameters of complex models are
actually relevant um in a very precise sense that
they don't actually make any input any impact on
on observables that you'd be able to see in an
experiment um and and then what i'm going to tell
you is that a simpler model um in a very concrete
way actually learns more from an experiment
um so that that that's one of the things that that
i'm going to be arguing for here and the second
thing is that it should still be possible um so
if you think that the reason you should prefer
a simpler model is that most parameters don't
matter um then it seems intuitively that you
ought to be able to use a more complicated model
if you don't know how to reduce your model um and
i'm gonna argue that indeed you can still use a
complicated model to make unbiased predictions
okay so um uh so i want to motivate the idea of
making a parameter ensemble and and i'm going
to do that by showing this climate model or
this is not a climate model but but but to to
tell you about um a goal of climate modeling so
um so here the temperature anomaly
is from 1880 to 2018 um and
a model for this would have a lot of diverse data
you can sort of imagine what that would be you
could build a very complicated multi-parameter
model and one goal of this would be to predict
the future of climate so you'd
want to be able to predict
what this map might look like in the future and
i think you'd agree that that that the reason
this is difficult is because we can't pin down all
the parameters so for example um we might not know
how much uh of an influence melting snow will
have on increasing the absorption of radiation
um uh and and and and one idea of a parameter
ensemble is that that we can get a quantitative
handle on it um with an approach uh schematically
like this um so what i want to do is is make the
probability for future predictions be some sort
of an average over over my model uncertainty um
so this part here is some integral over possible
values my parameters might have very schematically
and for each one i want to weight the
probability of a particular prediction
and to go into a little bit more detail these
terms that i've colored blue those are related
to how consistent each possible model is to the
data that i already have um so i'm going to fit
my model to existing data whatever that might be
um and whoop and this red term which is going to
be the subject of of this talk is about deciding
on what measure to give um to parameter space so
i'm going to be talking about this in the context
of an uninformative prior but i want you to think
about this as just being a measure on the space
of parameters um that this model could have and
in particular you want a measure that really gives
equal weight to every distinguishable prediction
um so so every model that makes a different
prediction you want to give equal weight to
okay so i'm going to give the
central claims of this talk
first and and one of them is that this
approach can work even if my model has
too many parameters um so even if i don't
know how to reduce it to a model that
every parameter is independently fit by the
claim is that you can still use this approach
but the prior that that is most often we used in
this context jeffrey's prior um i will explain
what that is and i'll i'll tell you that jeffrey's
prior actually introduces extreme bias if i use
it for a model that has too many parameters um
and the reason that i'm going to give it to you
qualitatively now is that jeffrey's prior really
conflates two distinct notions of parameter space
measure um so what i told you is that what
we're looking for is a measure that gives
equal weight to every distinguishable prediction
um and in this space that i'm showing you here
inside of the green is the space of possible
models and on this space there's a measure which
where distance is measured in in terms
of standard deviations um and equally
distinguishable predictions i can qualitatively
do by putting this model on some graph paper
and roughly whenever my model
goes through one of these squares
that means it's distinguishable from its nearby
models and i want to give that equal weight
what are the axes of this plot i will explain
in detail what the axes of this plot are
but for now um these are different models so
so different points in this are different model
parameters and the distance between points is
how easy it would be to distinguish them from
data in units of standard deviations um so this
is the goal is to do a weighting on parameter
space something like how many squares does this
go through and and i want to highlight that this
is very different from weighting things by their
volume in particular here there's the same number
of blobs as there are squares here um but you can
see that this gives very little weight to this end
of the model space here um because it's very thin
even though um this thinness is much less than one
so there's no reason to care about whether you can
distinguish models on one side or the other anyway
um so what i'm going to argue is that this
really gets to be a very extreme problem in high
dimension and that this is the reason jeffrey's
prior doesn't work so that's where we're going
and i'm also going to introduce an unbiased
optical measure and for this particular model
this is what that weighting would look like yeah
yeah does it does it matter if the different
models have structured like some hierarchical
structure to them and i guess what i mean is in
the biological case you can have a huge network
you're just asking like which which reduction
of that network it makes the most sense or gives
the most predictive power in the case of climate
models you can actually say i'm using the same
theory i'm just taking different approximations
of the navier stokes and i'm deciding whether
to do that on a 2d sphere or in a 3d system
and and how many terms is it hydrostatic or
not how many terms do i keep around like is
is that an important distinction yeah so uh what
the the prior that that that i'll be advocating
for in this talk um if you if you apply it to
a model with too many parameters it will do a
weighted sum of the different sub models um so uh
so um we haven't looked at climate models at all
um uh just a motivating example but i'm sure that
it would do this it would pick out um you know a
collection of different possible simplifications
of the big model class if that answers yep
okay so so that that's what i'm uh that's where
i'm going um to give an outline i'm first gonna
uh introduce some statistics i'm gonna talk
about the fisher information metric which is
um the measure on the space that i just showed
you um i'm gonna uh talk about sloppiness and
hyperurban geometries and in particular tell you
about a particular structure that these models
have um i'm going to tell you uh that edges are
simpler models um so we were just discussing this
a little bit um and now i'm going to give a little
bit of an introduction to uninformative priors
and then i'm going to tell you about what's
really new in this talk i'm going to tell you
about priors which maximize the mutual information
between parameters and the data that they will
see i'm going to tell you that jeffrey's prior
actually introduces this extreme bias um by using
this incorrect measure okay um so just uh to to
get everyone on the same page with some statistics
um and notation i'm always going to be talking
about parameters theta um and and inferring
those parameters from data x um and so here's an
example um i might have a model that's a sum of
exponentials so a sum of n exponentials and i want
to fit the rates at which these decay that's going
to make a deterministic prediction why and i'm
going to make the assumption that that my data is
of the form that it's gaussian distributed around
the deterministic value of y so the probability of
x is going to be a multivariate gaussian centered
on the deterministic predictions of the model
and and one approach to understanding models
this way is is looking for the maximum likelihood
estimate so this is the the parameter theta which
maximizes the probability of having to produce
the data i don't have the sum of the exponentials
all the same weight i mean could they be different
weights they could change anything and what you're
saying it does change uh it qualitatively changes
the picture um it doesn't uh sorry quantitatively
changes the picture um uh it turns out that the
models i'm going to be showing i'll have this
form um um it won't qualify change things
so i'm a little bit confused about the notation
in your likelihood p of x yes given theta um
there's no theta on the right hand side is
that yeah the theta is implicit through y
so is y a conditional distribution or is it a
parameterized function yeah i'm sorry so why is a
is the term is a deterministic
function of theta given by this
is a deterministic function of t parameterized by
thing um it's a distribution over t parameterized
by theta there's it's a deterministic function
of t and theta i'm sorry i should not have this
bar here that should probably be a comma if
that's um so y is a function of t and theta um and
the probability distribution on x that is
um you know that this is a um this depends
on theta um implicitly or implicitly because of
the dependence on y so we could just make it all
work by getting rich by changing that vertical
bar in the first one to a comma and then in the
second one rather than we y of t i will be y of t
i comma theta sure yes okay got it thank you yes
okay and so uh so um so the maximum likelihood
estimate on theta is is just the theta which
maximizes this okay so at the best fit i
can take a derivative with respect to theta
of of the probability um and i get zero right
so it's it's the best fit um and and the next
thing i can do is define the hessian of of
of this um so this is the second derivative
of the probability distribution now this is the
best fit um and so uh the hessian is going to
be positive when it's defined this way um and
uh uh it's it's symmetric and positive definite
um and so it defines really uh confidence
ellipses as i get close to the best fit
so if these ellipses are long that means i can
move a long way in parameter space before i get
a model with a substantially different cost if the
ellipses are short that means i don't have to move
very far before my data rules out those parameter
values okay so so that's the hessian and i want
to quickly switch to thinking about the fissure
information so before i actually see any data
i can define the fischer information as
the expectation value of the hesse given
the data that arises from that model so this
is going to be the second derivative of log p
but in expectation value um given the the
expected data that i'm going to see um this
is still positive and symmetric definite
and and now this actually defines um oh
good enough
okay so this um this this defines a romanian
metric on the space and what that means is i can
i can think about um a proper distance if you
will um between models that are close by in space
um and this distance is really going to be
measured in units of standard deviations
so it's it's a measure of how distinguishable
two close by models are going to be
from the data that one of them will produce
okay um so um the the the main point about
sloppy models and i'm going to explain why
this is is that g is positive it's symmetric um
and its eigenvalues are evenly spaced and log
um so let me just show you some examples of that
these are models um from a variety of different
areas of science um here's discrete diffusion
which i'll actually talk about a little bit
um this is a multi-parameter icing model
and this is the sum of exponentials
um uh and this is that systems biology
model that i showed you at the beginning
um and uh and and what you're seeing here is
the eigenvalues plotted in log space and and
what's really important about this is that they're
evenly distributed over many orders of magnitude
um and and this is not a random matrix ensemble
this is a very different ensemble um and and
uh physically what this means is that
there are some parameter combinations
that are orders of magnitude more easily to
infer uh from data than others so i i'm i'm
really confused like for say discrete diffusion
you know which is just one equation like how is
it that you trying to match it to like a sum of
exponentials what is that what's i will show you
the discrete diffusion in more detail that's
that's an example okay that i'll show so so um
that's an attempt to um to address this question
of why water um which is very complicated just has
the diffusion constant um but but but i guess the
what i what's what's really important from this
slide is that that here um a long direction so an
eigenvector with a large corresponding eigenvalue
um uh that will be very easy to infer that
parameter with high precision from data
whereas a small eigenvalue means that i can move
many orders of magnitude without changing the cost
okay so i can also think about this in
data space so for a least squares model
um the metric has this form um and um and what
um maybe if you're very good at embeddings
and geometry what you can see is that this is
just the form that's gotten um by embedding
uh the model parameters into the space of their
data um so here's an example of that if i just
um fit my sum of exponentials to
two data points these are shown here
i can think about the metric as coming about
by embedding each parameter into the space
of their data so now i'm plotting the second
data point y of t2 versus the first data point
um and and this is the metric space
of the fischer information right um
that's okay so um what i uh want you to take
from this is is firstly that even though the
parameters can go from zero to infinity right
there's no reason the rates couldn't be zero or
infinite um the information geometry space is
bounded um and and you can see that because no
matter what my parameters are um these two data
points the the y's that that they correspond to
will always go between zero and one so that
means they always need to fit in the square
and it's a funny shape because for example y of t2
needs to be smaller than y of t1 because they're
decaying exponentials so this is the space
is this is this okay people are
i mean i mean you're still i mean i'm still
not seeing the connection with like discrete
diffusion with just like one that's coming but but
the information geometry and that this is um the
metric that corresponds to the sum of exponentials
i guess is um what i hope is clear at this point
okay so um so as an experimental fact um when
i when i take one of these models and i look at
its uh uh model manifolds so the the manifold
that i was showing before in higher dimensions
um they have this characteristic structure that
they're uh we call them hyper ribbons um so uh so
here i'm i'm showing a sum of three exponentials
in three dimensional space and um what i hope
you can notice is that it has this very long
direction here um uh that that corresponds to
to this direction and two um then it has
a second direction um which is thinner
and a third direction which is
extremely thin and to remind you
distance measurements distinguishability
and this means that there are two parameters
that i might be able to infer from data but
the third one is extremely indistinguishable
rated it's very thin um any two models
that only differ in that third direction
are going to differ by a very small amount
so so ben i've got a really dumb question i'm
missing a little bit about what you mean about
embedding if i've got more data than parameters
um presumably you're going to
be embedding into a sub manifold
of the data space and i'm not really seeing
what is meant by that well for example
if i were the consequences of this so
for for example if i was just fitting
a single exponential to two data points
um then my model would just be this line
but a single model so okay with that but that
that dimension right there is the dimensionality
of the number of parameters it's not the
dimension of the number of data points if i had
three data points what would it mean to what
you're thinking about how exactly i embed a
two parameter model into a space with
three data points well um okay so so so
on this space which is two-dimensional
uh a model with just a single parameter
if if that has the same mystery that
would just be a line through this right
and so and if i you know if
i took a third data point
um you'd want to embed this in three dimensions
but i'd still have a sheet in three dimensions
um and that sheet would get its metric from its
embedding in three dimensions if that's okay okay
yeah i mean i understand algebraically i'm not
quite sure i understand the um what i'm going
to take away from the pictures but that's okay
well um i guess what i what i want you to take
is that um this has this particular structure of
being a hyper ribbon that has a very long axis
and then every successive axis is smaller by
by a geometric factor okay if that's okay yeah
okay so why why sloppiness um uh and and i think
in this model it's easy to understand this from
interpolation um so um so the sum of exponentials
actually has all sorts of um of constraints
um and and for example um once i fix a time
point at t equals a third um um i know that all
successive time points are going to be lower than
that right and that's because the first derivative
of any sum of exponentials um is always decreasing
um and and it turns out um after i've pinned that
down actually i'm sorry i should have first pinned
this one down but but every time i i pinned down a
successive data point i vastly constrain what the
other data points could do so um so it turns out
that each data point i constrain constrains all
of the other data points by a geometric factor
and that's one way of understanding why you get
this particular structure and just to highlight
this in a slightly more general way a predictive
model is really not the same as just curb fitting
so in curve fitting if i have a high enough
order polynomial i can go through all of
these points um but if you have a mechanistic
model it's not like that in this particular way
that intermediate points will constrain other
points so so committing yourself to modeling
some data as a sum of exponentials is very
different from curve fitting it's saying
that you know something about the problem and you
don't expect a general polynomial um you expect a
curve that has a negative first derivative and a
positive second derivative and so on and so forth
okay so um hopefully this is to answer
your question um uh i i think this is a
slightly different reason um from from why
um uh the sum of exponential expanded um
the sum exponentials um for for
this example um in general your
your statements are true if the sum is fine
um it's true even if the sum is not finite
as long as i prohibit myself from using
um exponentials with positive exponents
so as long as all the exponentials are decreasing
this holds if that's okay does that make sense
um not sure but it's not important
um okay so um so to get at this question that
that um you're asking for sid um uh one thing you
could imagine is a model um uh for for microscopic
hopping so the particular model that we considered
um had a particle that every time step um could
have to one of its six nearest neighbor sites or
stay where it is um so this model has seven
parameters if you allow it to non-conserve
um uh particle number or six parameters if you
wanted to conserve particle number um and and you
could ask if you're able to see the distribution
at some later time points how easy would it be to
look at these parameters and so if you look after
just a single time point um really you can measure
each parameter independently right so if i um
if i start a bunch of particles at the origin
i wait one time step um and i look at the density
um i would be able to measure all seven of those
parameters independently um but you know that as
time evolves if i let them hop according to this
repeatedly that the central limit theorem
says that eventually they should reach a
gaussian and a gaussian has two parameters or in
this case three if we allow it to non-conserve
particle density um and and indeed if you look
at the fischer information after many time steps
what you see is that there's this hierarchy
that develops um so the largest one um
is non-conservation of particle number the
longer i wait the easier it's going to be
to see whether the particles are destroyed
or creating more of themselves um the next
one is the drift so this is a relative a relevant
parameter and an rg analysis and indeed the longer
you wait easier it is to detect a small drift the
next one is the diffusion constant um and then
all these further uh uh parameters don't have
names but they uh parametrize things like the
third cumulent of the resulting distribution and
so on and so forth um and and so the claim is that
this is sort of a general feature that when
you look at models that are coarse-grained
much more than their microscopic scale they will
have a structure like this okay um here is just a
another way to think about this um here the blue
particles and red particles have a very different
kernel when they hop a single time step but
we've carefully matched them to have the same
diffusion constant and zero drift so if you wait
for a while these distributions become identical
um and and here looking back at that um original
distribution what i'm showing you is just um
the principal component analysis of the
information geometry space and what you can see is
that these two kernels which look very different
microscopically get very close as time evolves
okay so our simple model is available um so in
hyper ribbon um every point is close to an hitch
in fact a very high dimensional edge um and if you
look at this example more carefully um it turns
out that the three edges have have names so one
of them um or or are writable downable um so for
example this edge here um this is a one parameter
model where i've set the two exponentials uh k1 to
equal k2 another thing i can do is set one
of the exponentials to have a rate of zero
or a rate of infinity um and and in this example
at least edges are simpler models with one less
parameter um and um and really elegant work um
that i had no involvement with from from mark um
mark showed that this is actually quite general
um and he developed a a a method to iteratively go
to the edges the closest edge of the model um
write down the reduced model and then and then
keep iterating this procedure and that's actually
how we did this model simplification that i showed
at the beginning so he started with this very
complicated model um and by iteratively going to
the edges he found this reduced model an edge of
the higher dimensional model which is very close
okay so just just to recap this the fischer
information measures distance if i look at
typical models um their their geometry has this
type ribbon structure um and and in particular
the edges are simpler models okay so i want
to move to talking about bayesian inference
um and uh my mother sent me this my mom uh
uh this onion article um and actually uh the
title is awesome but actually this is a reasonable
abstract for this talk we're going to learn how to
use statistical analysis to assess priors minimize
biases and anyway i was very amused um but i do
want to start by recapping bayesian priors and
model selection um so so bayes theorem is math um
here is the math i can derive the probability of x
and y happening together in two different ways one
is i can multiply the probability of x times the
probability of y given x or i could do the reverse
and if you set these equal to each other you
derive bayes theorem so you can't argue with this
it's just mathematics um but the bayesian approach
to statistics um sweeps something under the rug
um which is that if you want to apply this you
really need a prior and the idea is that um uh
what i would really like is to understand the
probability of different parameters that's p of
theta given the data that i've seen and i can use
bayes rule so my my model makes a prediction for
the probability of different outcomes um and and
i can use bayes rule as long as i have this prior
um now if you're if your distribution has a prior
there's nothing wrong but it's kind of a hand wavy
thing to do because it's not really parameterizing
a probability distribution right your prior is is
really parameterizing um your uncertainty about
the world right if you really have the right model
the correct prop the correct parameters would be a
delta function somewhere you just don't know where
and it's a little bit hokey to parameterize your
uncertainty with the probability distribution in
this way um so how do you choose a prior um uh
what what i'm going to be advocating for here
is to choose one which maximizes the amount
that you'll learn from your experiment
okay so the first thing i need to convince
you of is that a flat priority stick
um so for example um uh if i'm trying to estimate
k1 and k2 here and i just have a flat prior um um
um what i want you to notice is that um this
would put all of the weight at k1 and k2 infinite
right so there's infinite parameter space
there and so actually all of my prior weight
is going to be effectively on this one
model that decays instantaneously right
so um so not only is that weird because the
prior puts all of its weight on this one
effective model it also learns nothing from
experiment and and that's because even though um
this model is not terribly close to the
experimental data it's not infinitely far
away so when i update my model according to bayes
rule um the posterior will also look like this
another way to argue against the flat prior is
that this parametrization is somewhat arbitrary
um so i could have instead asked
to estimate tau one and tau two
this is um clearly the same model right this is
another reasonable way to parameterize the model
um but this would actually give totally different
predictions right so um so so if i parametrize it
this way my flat tire would instead say your model
should never decay and again i've learned nothing
from data so this is not re-parameterization
environment and it learns nothing from data
okay so jeffrey's prior takes its measure from
the experiment that you're going to perform
um and as motivation jeffries argued
that the idea is as as i was saying
before that you should put equal
weight on every distinguishable model
um and jeffrey's prior is literally the volume
element of the fischer information matrix
so it depends on the expected data because
the fisher information does um and um and
and i guess what you should take from this is
that jeffrey's prior is equally waiting volume
in this space here in this case area right okay
so uh jeffrey's prior is sick from models which
are hypervenoms and i think the easiest way to see
this is is by looking at this so um so jeffrey's
prior is going to measure the n-dimensional volume
in this case this is the three-dimensional volume
here but i think you'd probably agree that this is
effectively a two-dimensional model here um and as
a result weighting it by by its three-dimensional
volume doesn't make a lot of sense and it's going
to suffer from this problem that i showed you
before um that that if i weight things by their
equal intrinsic volumes um maybe what you can
see here is that this edge which is very thin
and you can see that because there aren't very
many circles here um i should say that this is
sampled according to jeffrey's prior um um that
doesn't really reflect um that these models are
are just as distinguishable right um they're the
equivalent of being somewhere out in the tail here
okay so what we really want is a prior which is
not just invariant to changes in parameterization
but a prior which is invariant to adding a
parameter that can't be seen so we want a prior
um that if i add a a parameter that doesn't do a
whole lot um it should give similar predictions
okay and um what we're going to advocate for is
maximizing the mutual information between the
parameters and their expected data and and i can
write this in two different ways so one is the
entropy and parameter space minus the entropy in
parameter space after i see my data um and i could
alternatively write it as the reduction in entropy
in the data space after i tell you the parameters
so i have to argue for you that this is
a natural thing to do um and and mutual
information i would argue really uh quantifies
how much you expect to learn from an experiment
um so this is an optimist interpretation um if i
write the the mutual information as the entropy
in parameter space minus the entropy and parameter
space after i see my data then i think maybe you'd
agree with me this is a good quantification of
how much i'm going to learn from an experiment
another way that you can argue for this um
is is what i call a pessimist interpretation
and this is that well you really don't know what
your parameters are um but you want your your um
uh you want your your model your your
prior um to minimize the worst case
so whatever the worst case probability
distribution is um and and i can quantify
that by asking what the kl divergence is between a
particular model um and and my p of x which comes
from the prior um if i want to minimize that this
is actually equivalent so ben yes yeah i've often
this is a part of the um uh the approach
that i've often been confused by because
there are many justifications of course for why
you want to quantify everything with a probability
distribution to reflect your uncertainty and so
on and so forth there's definitely's arguments
cox's algorithms et cetera et cetera from
a sort of more high-level point of view you
might want to say this is what um god thinks
the distribution over possible realities is
in the situation that we're
facing you are instead here though
not choosing the anything based upon what god
might have done anything based upon my uncertainty
you're instead saying i'm just going to it feels
like cheating i'm just going to choose my prior
so that whatever god decides so long as he's
using my prior i'm telling god what to do
i'm going to then be able to just um use my
data maximally so i'm saying god use my prior
that'll make life easier for me so
you can phrase this as a betting
this is the optimal strategy of what
i would say is a betting game with god
so um so the game is i get to choose my
prior um and then uh my prior determines
what i think is going to happen it determines
the probability distribution on the data um
and then god's allowed to look at my prior and
choose the actual parameter values of the system
um and we're going to bet on the outcome and and
fkl is actually my expected loss in this game so
that's um you know that's how much i will lose
if if god chooses parameter values data and and
one way to phrase maximizing mutual information
is you're trying to minimize the worst case loss
okay i think that is a little bit more
compelling in this game it's an iterative game
you're assuming i guess yeah so this is assuming
it's a one-shot game you write down your prior
you haven't seen any data yet um um there's
other versions of it but the way you derive
the mutual information maximizing prior it's
just a one-shot game okay to be honest that
that's more compelling i think than the other
argument okay okay thank you awesome yeah
uh they're they're formally equivalent you know
i can i can understand that but what strikes
me is telling god what to do and the other
thing i need to protect myself against god
yeah i think um um well okay i would call
this the pessimist interpretation right
god is trying to trick you uh as opposed to
you're hoping to learn as much as possible
but i agree they're uh it's
interesting that they agree um okay
um okay so um here are some results so um uh
if if if if what we're going to do is just flip
a coin some number of times um and what you're
trying to infer is is the probability of the head
um here are some priors and this doesn't look like
the other priors i've been showing you and that's
because the optimal prior is typically discrete
so this optimal prior is actually composed of
a finite number of delta functions so if i'm only
going to flip one head this prior puts half of its
weight on a head and half of its weight on a tail
um so so the prior is just two delta functions
one at 100 percent of the time heads one at
100 of the time tails um if you're going to
flip the coin many times then it starts putting
intermediate points uh putting weight on inter
sorry then it starts putting weight on
intermediate points um and as i increase
the number of repetitions um eventually the
optimal prior approach is jeffrey's prior so
the limit of infinite data or infinite repetitions
this optimal prior does reproduce jeffrey's prior
but only in the limit of infinite repetitions
um so you could ask why discreetness
um and formally when you look for a prior
which maximizes the mutual information
subject to the constraint that the uh prior
is normalized um what you get is that the kl
divergence uh between parameters and the data is a
constant um but subject to the inequality um that
that the prior's weight at that point is greater
than zero um and and so the solution is actually
given by either the probability of of having
weight on a particular or the weight on a
particular theta in the prior should be zero or
the the fkl the kl divergence between um this
model and the total model should be a constant
and so just to give you a picture of what this
looks like um here's the kl divergence this fkl
of theta this is how much you expect to lose um
in this game should god choose that parameter
value and what you can see is that it's a
constant wherever my prioritized weight and it's
always lower than that constant everywhere else
okay so that's why this is discrete um and uh and
now what i want to show you is what this prior
looks like for two exponentials um and and um so
as before this prior is still discrete um and at
large noise it actually only has weight on these
two corners and at this single point in the middle
which is geometrically the farthest from those
um as i decrease sigma so as i make my error
bars smaller and smaller and my data gets better
i start to fill in this one-dimensional model here
and remember that's a simpler model right that's
that's a single exponential um and as my weight
as sorry as my air blocks get smaller and smaller
um i start to put weight in the center and i start
to fill in this um this full two-dimensional
model um so eventually the weight even is in
the full-dimensional model um and i can look at
one notion of the effective dimensionality of my
model um by looking at the fraction of the weight
that's on zero one and two dimensional models
so maybe this is getting at your question from
earlier that indeed this is picking out mostly
reduced models um but a combination
of a few different reduced models
okay so um uh one thing i want to highlight is
that this is adapting the dimensionality not
just in that sense of of sitting on progressively
higher dimensionality sub models but also in terms
of how it's spreading its weight out so um if i
look at at an intermediate value when i uh when i
haven't you know when when the data is better but
still not great i am filling in uh models along
this whole line but i'm roughly evenly spaced
not in two dimensions but in one dimension um
and then as i increase the the quality of my
data i start to put more weight if i just look
in one dimension in this center region because
there's a second dimension to explore there
so what i want you to note is that if i started
with this prior over here that would actually be
very biasing along this one-dimensional model
that i'm effectively exploring when i don't
have a lot of data right because this model
is putting most of its weight in the center
and very little out on the edges here and if
i can only infer one one parameter anyway um
that's very biasing along that single dimension
um so this is in a two-dimensional model um but
this is more extreme than a four-dimensional model
um so now um this is a four-dimensional model and
and um because of of the limitations of the
screen you're just seeing it in two dimensions
and and the optimal prior starts out being pretty
evenly distributed along one dimension eventually
it becomes nicely distributed along two and now
here you can start to see that it's getting some
extra weight in the center here and that's because
in the two dimensions that you're not seeing the
manifold is getting thicker and by the time
you look at jeffrey's prior now this is just um
uh stochastically sampled you
can see that it's really avoiding
these edges of the model manifold even
though there should be weight there
okay so how bad is jeffree's prior here in this
dimension four that i was showing you um it's not
actually so terrible so this is the sum of before
exponential sampled at five data points um and
what you can see is that jeffrey's prior jeffrey's
prior doesn't depend on the amount of data
so it's the same for all of these um but it
really avoids the edges of this model manifold
and and and that's true of the optimal
prior but only after it's been sampled
with very high um or sorry only
after the data quality is very good
and if i quantify this by looking at the mutual
information what you can see is that when data is
bad there's actually a big gap between the amount
of information that i get from the optimal prior
and from jeffrey's prior okay so this is in
dimension four so the sum of four exponentials
fit to five data points um and now i want to
show you what happens in much higher dimension
so um jeffrey's prior is very biasing in high
dimension um so um to get you used to looking
at this plot um now this data is being taken
um uh in 26 dimensions um but for now this is
still a three-dimensional model and you can see
a trace of that that there's three peaks here
um this is at a sigma of one-tenth um and and
what you're seeing here is the optimal prior
and blue so it's still composed of a bunch of
delta functions um jeffrey's prior and orange
and another prior which is commonly used the
log normal prior in pink um and as before
sorry i also need to tell you
what you're seeing here so this is
um the first two principal components of of of
the fischer information space of the data space
okay and and and what i want you to see here is
that the optimal prior is very spread out along
this it looks evenly distributed along these two
principal components um and jeffrey's prior is
not right it's somewhat biased to the left-hand
side here there's another way that i can display
this prior which is by plotting it um versus
time um and you can see that the blue points
are really spread out here um and jeffrey's prior
and log normal or less spread out right so um just
qualitatively um jeffrey's prior in the la normal
prior are much less spread out in data space
okay um however they're not so bad in
the sense that if i then take some data
over here which is somewhat far from where
jeffrey's prior is located all of these are
able to do a reasonably good job of updating
to make a posterior that looks like the data
okay but i can also look at this model
in 26 dimensions so so now this is the
sum of 26 exponentials um and a few things
to notice firstly the optimal prior looks
pretty similar right so it's it's it's now
flat on the top here um and that's because
there's 26 different reduced models that you can
choose that sort of smoothly interpolate here
but it's still roughly covering this space
but jeffrey's prior is now very different so
jeffrey's prior is totally confined
to this very small region over here
and that's because this region is much thicker
in the 24 dimensions that you haven't seen
um and even though you can't see those other 24
dimensions they're still much thinner than one
um they're biasing jeffrey's prior to sit
over here i think this is more clear here so
so the optimal prior looks pretty similar to the
three-dimensional case except maybe very far to
the left over here um but jeffrey's prior is now
very tightly constrained to this region in here
um so and and um and let me just say that that
now um the optimal prior still does a good job
of updating um after i see data but jeffrey's
prior is very biased now so jeffrey's pryor
is sort of an interpolation between this point
that for some reason jefferies prior is very
heavily weighted towards um and where the actual
data is so jeffrey's prior introduces a bias that
really shifts the mean of the posterior
over by many many standard deviations
okay so the mutual information also declines
precipitously for jeffrey's fire so the optimal
prior um if i plot its mutual information versus
the number of parameters um i'm sorry that should
be d here the number of parameters um what
i see is that um as i increase the number of
parameters initially i do a better job i have
larger visual information and then once i have
enough parameters to fit the data pretty well the
mutual information saturates on the other hand
for jeffries prior going from one to two
parameters doesn't cause a problem but as i
go higher than this um because of this issue that
all of my weight gets centered at the very center
of this 24-dimensional 26-dimensional manifolds
the mutual information drops off precipitously
okay so where did jeffrey's prior go wrong here
um so the mutual information really measures the
number of distinguishable states um and and then
spreads out the mass of the prior to minimize
the overlap so it really tries to maximize the
number of distinct models that you can count
and on the other hand the fissure volume is
really measuring the d-dimensional volume
regardless of the dimensionality of the actual
data that i'm seeing and and i think one way
to quantify this is that the fissure volume
um is really a product of of the relative
the relevant volume um and and what i'd like to
call an irrelevant cobalt um and it's variation in
this irrelevant co volume that really distorts the
relevant space um so um just to give a schematic
maybe don't treat this as an actual equation but a
way of thinking about it um jeffrey's prior uh is
waiting by the proper volume element but what we
really want is is the volume element just in the
space of relevant parameters so what we want is
the volume element here in this two-dimensional
space that i'm showing you um but jeffrey's prior
is measuring um the volume in the 26-dimensional
space and you can think of that as the product
of the local volume element the one that we want
times the local code volume so how thick
the space is in the other 24 dimensions
and and what you can see from this is that
those other 24 dimensions for probably not
very interesting reasons are very thick right here
and they're very thin as i move away from this
okay so that's a qualitative picture um to be a
little bit more quantitative maximizing the mutual
information sets the distance to all the models to
be equal so it sets fkl to be equal and the mutual
information is really the average of fkl so what
i can define is a bias pressure which measures um
how much the mutual information were to increase
where do i increase where i to increase the weight
on that particular parameter value and this
bias is just fkl minus mutual information
and uh i claim that this roughly quantifies
the minus log of the irrelevant code volume
okay um and and just looking at that here i
haven't talked about the color scheme on this
um but if you were to weight this particular
model with jeffrey's prior um what you would
find is that there's a huge bias pressure at the
corner here um because even though it's weighted
by the proper volume um this is very far from
from from from where there's a lot of weight
and so i could increase the mutual information
a lot by increasing the weight over here
okay so um so so what went so wrong um the
essential problem is that jeffrey's prior is
not spread evenly along the relevance of space
instead it's it's it's being weighted um by this
irrelevant co-volume um and just to quantify
a little bit more um why this causes problems
um what you can see here is um here here's the
optimal prior in blue and jeffrey's prior in red
and what you can ask is if i get a data point
at one of these points marked with an x um and
then i calculate my posterior and ask where its
centroid is so where its center of mass is um um
where the ends of these orange lines are is where
jeffree spread will put it if that makes sense
so i gave one example of that before a model that
was over here and had its centroid way over here
um and this is a more global picture of that
and what you can see is that jeffrey's prior
often well it always wants to move whatever data
it sees towards this point in the middle here
where for whatever reason um the model in
the other 24 dimensions is thicker um and
and this is really kind of an everyday picture
of bias right that that jeffries prior will will
push um the predictions of the model away
from whatever data you've seen um and there
are similar lines for blue for the optimal prior
so it's not identically zero but it's very small
um and what you're seeing um in the lower plot is
a plot of this posterior deviation that's really
the length of this line on the x-axis and this
bias b of theta on the y-axis and just to show um
that that these two measures sort of agree right
that arc quantification of bias bias pressure
is similar um to this everyday usage of moves your
model's predictions away from the data you've seen
okay um uh i just to uh talk uh more broadly
and philosophically for for a moment um this
this approach does pose a little bit of a problem
for basians so lindley is famous for saying that
today's posterior is tomorrow's prior um and
the idea is that um that you can just keep
iterating this um so um so i i get some data i
update my prior and i get a posterior and now
if i get some new data what i should do is
just keep doing another bayesian update um
and and and and what i want to stress
is that that's not actually true here
um so um so if i get new data um in this framework
i also need to update my prior right because the
prior actually depends on what data i'm going
to get um so we can talk after about how much
this should bother you um one thing i would point
out is that this is also true of jeffrey's prior
unless you carry out exactly the same experiment
so if i look at my data and i design a slightly
different experiment even in jeffrey's prior i
need to update my prior um but jeffrey's prior
does have the property that if you repeat
the experiment you never need to update it
okay so just to wrap up what i've said is
that the mutual information really quantifies
learning from a prior then i introduced the
idea of mutual information optimal priors
um they're discreet they're they're sort
of interesting in this way that they
um select simple models in a way that i
think is quite different from from from other
other reasons to prefer a simple model um i've
shown that they approached jeffries prior but
only in the limit of infinite data and then the
things that i really want to focus on here um
is that jeffree's prior is very biasing when
there are many parameters but not a ton of data
and the reason for this is because it
re-weights by the irrelevant code volume
but if instead you use a prior which is optimal
in the sense of maximizing the mutual information
you will not get any bias from this
particular issue um i wanna uh uh thank
my collaborators in particular michael abbott
who's really um been leading this work um and
um and really did all of the work on quantifying
um why jeffrey's prior performed so badly
um uh uh in addition this this a lot of this
work was done with henry mattingly um was also
um henry was also a major player in
the works that i talked about last time
and this work grew out of a long-standing
project of jim stephens to understand the
structure of typical models um uh and sloppiness
and and i talked about mark's work um in
particular thinking about the edges of model
manifolds um and with that i'll take questions
okay thank you very much so um there were a bunch
of questions um during the talk um i know that i
am interrupted at several points do other
people have other questions to add to the list
michael go ahead
and i have to admit that i didn't understand
anything but i have i have a one question
is i don't understand so you said that with
infinite data you converge to jeffries prior
with i mean infinite uh future data
so can you explain right then you also explain
to us how come jeffrey's prior is so biased
and bad so how come jeffrey's prior is so good
with infinite data so i think the way i would
ben you're silent
nope silent
um did you touch something or
scott can you hear can you help
nope
look at this scott
but now yeah now i can hear
it do you know what i did nope
okay i have an answer uh so um okay so um i think
what's what's really important is that um uh the
the the fisher information space which jeffrey's
prior takes its metric from or its measure from
um is not it it is dimensionless um so so
distances are measured in units of standard
deviations and this means there's an important
distinction um between widths that are smaller
than one and widths that are larger than one
um and and what you want to do in the optimal
prior um is pay attention to the volume in widths
that are um larger than one and ignore widths that
are smaller than one right so so i would say and
this maps nicely onto the renormalization group
meaning of irrelevant that with smaller than one
are really irrelevant right they don't um if you
move around in in those parameter space directions
you move your parameters a lot but you don't get
different predictions um and and so when you have
finite data it's important that you don't wait by
the volume in this irrelevant direction but if you
have infinite data then all of the widths are much
larger than one all the widths are infinite and so
this distinction between relevant and irrelevant
becomes unimportant um and and jeffrey's
prior is the right thing to use because
you really in that limit you really can infer
even irrelevant parameters and maybe a way
to see this is you know if you have a tabletop
particle accelerator you could measure the higgs
mass if you really have infinite data um
uh so you know that the the the distinction
between parameters that you can measure and
parameters that you can't measure um you know
there's still a distinction of how well you
can measure that survives to infinite data
but with truly infinite data you
could measure all of the parameters
does that answer your question at all
yeah to some degree i mean a bit what you're
saying is that jeffrey's prior is correct when
it doesn't matter jeffrey's prior is i'm not going
to touch my keyboard but can you say that again
jeffrey's prior is correct when it doesn't match
them exactly so priors are always derived in
this limit of infinite data and that's the
limit where a prior doesn't matter at all
um exactly yeah it's not just jeffries
no prior matters an infinite data limit
so long as the prior doesn't has full support
you're always going to get the right answer
that that's that is true yes yes there's
nothing specific to jeffries at all
yeah and i think um there's a sense in which um
so jeffrey's prior is derived by considering this
um this asymptotic limit of of very large
amounts of data and there is a sense that
that's pathological because that's you know
that's where it doesn't matter what prior you use
and you mean it considers that limit in the sense
that it looks at the determinant of the um square
the square root of the term of the fischer metric
and you're saying that the fischer metric it can
be viewed as an infinite data limit but you could
also just use the fischer metric that are saying
expectation for a single data point yeah so i i
don't i mean so you can drive jeffrey's prior um
by considering a prior which maximizes the mutual
information and that requires the infinite data
limit you can argue for jeffries prior in ways
that don't require the infinite data limit i agree
do we have other questions then
maybe one last thing about the infinite data limit
i think many people would say well um if you truly
have infinite data um then the prior doesn't
matter but you know the really relevant cases
when you have um a lot of data um and in that case
the prior is close to jeffrey's prior and and that
would justify it and that seems sort of reasonable
and i think that's true if you have a small model
um or that can can be true in a small model but
if you have a model with a lot of parameters
you're typically in the case that you are in
the large data limit for some of the parameters
and not for others um and i guess
that's the particular case that we think
um jeffrey's prior is surprisingly distorting
for okay do we have other questions there
okay well um virtual claps again where do
we do this like yeah yeah yeah there we go
so thank you ben this is really been um very
unfortunate the way everything has not come
together as opposed to coming yeah uh uh um yeah
between diseases and uh snowstorms and oh god um
but so i sent you an email um
well i was wondering if you and